wir beginnen heute mit den
themenbereichen finanzen und haushalt
für die aussprache ist eine dauer von 90
minuten vorgesehen
das wort hat
davon geht jedenfalls aus
der bundesminister der finanzen für die
bundesregierung ja unser auftakt
natürlich seines ressorts
hat die einleitung
kristallin der bundesfinanzminister
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren die finanzpolitik wurde in
den vergangenen jahren durch die korona
pandemie bestimmt die finanzpolitik wird
auch gegenwärtig von der pandemie
geprägt die aufgabe der kommenden vier
jahre wird es sein aus dem
finanzpolitischen krisenmanagement
gestaltungs modus zu wechseln
erstens
erstens die bundesregierung arbeitet
daran im jahre 2023 zum regelfall der
schuldenbremse des grundgesetzes
zurückzukehren in den folgejahren ist es
mein ziel die deutsche schuldenquote zu
reduzieren es ist ein gebot der klugheit
nach einer krise die fiskalischen
handlungsfähigkeit des staates für
künftige krisen zu stärken
noch länger werden wären die folgen der
pandemie sehen deshalb reservieren wir
im klima- und transformations- form mit
dem zweiten nachtragshaushalt
ungenutzt ich sage lediglich ungenutzte
möglichkeiten des vorjahres um pandemie
bedingt ausgefallene investitionen
nachzuholen und um impulse zur
wirtschaftlichen belebung nach der
pandemie zu setzen dabei konzentrieren
wir uns auf den wachstumstreiber wie den
klimaschutz für die regulären vorhaben
der koalition
soll aber 2023 indessen wieder die
schuldenbremse gelten klima und
transformations- fonds einerseits
rückkehr zur schuldenbremse andererseits
damit verbinden wir investitionen in die
zukunft mit der disziplin bei
konsumausgaben in der gegenwart dem
gebot des bundesverfassungsgerichts nach
generationengerechtigkeit werden wir so
gerecht und zwar gar in doppelter weise
meine damen und herren die
verschiedentlich auch aus der union ins
gespräch der aufweichung ist gespräch
gebrachte aufweichung der schuldenbremse
des grundgesetzes lehnen der ab das wäre
eine einladung wie früher
verteilungspolitik zulasten der zukunft
zu betreiben denn nicht alles
wünschenswerte kann sofort finanziert
werden nicht jedes programm ist
fortschritt für deutschland ausgaben
müssen priorisiert werden es muss gelten
dass der wohlstand erst erwirtschaftet
wird bevor er danach verteilt werden
kann
meine damen und herren in dem sorgsamen
umgang mit haushaltsmitteln fühle ich
mich auch bereits jetzt verpflichtet das
zeigte der vorläufige kassenabschluss
des bundeshaushaltes
2021 den ich ihnen verehrte abgeordnete
hiermit mitteilte trotz des
nachtragshaushaltes müssen
24,8 milliarden euro weniger schulden
gemacht werden als von der
vorgängerregierung geplant damit wird
die nettokreditaufnahme
reduziert wir tun also das was nötig ist
aber es wird nicht ausgereizt was
möglich wäre
zweitens
unsere finanzpolitik sendet damit ein
signal über die deutschen grenzen hinaus
wir müssen die erholung der wirtschaft
finanzieren wir müssen die pandemie
überwinden wir müssen investitionen
stärken aber die bedeutung sozialer
solider staatsfinanzen die bedeutung
solider staatsfinanzen im zusammenhang
mit der inflation hat der neue präsident
der deutschen bundesbank
gerade erst angesprochen deshalb werden
wir bei allen herausforderungen
verbindliche fiskalregeln respektieren
und die verschuldung begrenzen diese
haltung vertreten wir in europa und auch
im rahmen unserer g7 präsidentschaft wir
werden also unseren beitrag leisten das
einmalige wiederaufbau instrument next
generation york zum erfolg zu führen es
kann und es muss neue wachstumschancen
eröffnen denn es ist nicht auf dauer
angelegt
der
europäische reform debatte werden wir
dann eben über eine weiterentwicklung
des stabilitäts und wachstumspaktes
sprechen für sinnvolle sind wir offen er
hat sich aber aus sicht der
bundesregierung mit seinen fiskalregeln
und seiner flexibilität im kern bewährt
die bundesregierung vertritt also das
transparente regeln und die
finanzpolitische eigenverantwortung der
mitgliedstaaten
unverzichtbare voraussetzungen für
stabilität sind
drittels
die bundesregierung versteht
finanzpolitik als ermöglichung politik
transformation
transformation technologien und
talentförderung erhalten im haushalts
priorität denn wir wollen ermöglichen
dass dieses land fortschritt wagt
es wird
es wird keine steuererhöhungen geben
stattdessen arbeiten wir an entlastungen
so im steuerlichen bereich bei der eeg
umlage bei der einführung des
bürgergeldes oder bei der privaten
eigentumsbildung deren wir wollen
ermöglichen dass deutschland attraktiv
bleibt als wirtschaftsstandort dass die
menschen in ihrem leben wirtschaftlich
vorankommen und dass der soziale
aufstieg für alle leichter gelingt
als ersten schritt arbeitet man mein
haus an einem neuen steuergesetz damit
sollen die verlängerung der home office
pauschale die verlängerung der
erweiterten verlustverrechnung längere
fristen für die abgabe von
steuererklärungen
steuerfreie zuschüsse zum
kurzarbeitergeld und die steuerbefreiung
für den pflege bonus von bis zu 3000
euro umgesetzt werden weitere schritte
werden im laufe der legislaturperiode
folgen
ich habe übrigens
ich habe übrigens auch genommen er
übrigens aufgenommen dass der
finanzminister von baden württemberg
jetzt verschiedentlich
steuerentlastungen für kleine und
mittlere einkommen ins gespräch gebracht
hat da sind wir jederzeit offen für
vorschläge allerdings halte ich es
unverändert nicht für ratsam die
entlastung der kleinen einkommen zu
koppeln an eine belastung des
mittelstands fach und führungskräfte
sowie die wirtschaft leisten bereits
heute an enormen beitrag zur
finanzierung des gemeinwesens wofür sie
anerkennung verdient haben
und ich nehme natürlich auch bei dass
aus den reihen der union jetzt ganz
aktuell forderungen nach einer
unternehmenssteuerreform geäußert werden
in der sache ist diese debatte durchaus
berechtigt aber wirklich sie hätten
allen ernstes jahre zeit gehabt hier
schritte auf den weg zu bringen
viertens
bei der gestaltung des finanzplatz
deutschland sind stabilität und
verbraucherschutz wichtige politische
ziele einem dritten und einem vierten
wollen wir aber mehr geltung verschaffen
nämlich wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
innovationskraft die bedingungen sind
gut wenn wir schauen wo das digitale
deutschland innovativ ist dann ist das
gerade die finanz branche fynn tags in
the text ripd venture capital startups
die haben ihr potenzial auch die drei
säulen unseres privaten bankwesens haben
perspektiven wir wollen also
anstrengungen unternehmen um deutschland
zu einem der führenden standorte zu
machen der finanzplatz deutschland kann
nicht nur wachstum finanzieren er soll
auch selbst zu einem wachstumsmotor
werden
fünftens die
bundesregierung für die steuererhebung
fehler machen zum einen wollen wir die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler von
lästigen vorgängen so weit es geht
entlasten zum beispiel durch die
möglichkeiten der digitalisierung
menschen sollen sich mit den schönen
dingen des lebens beschäftigen aber
nicht zu lange mit der steuererklärung
sofern es gehört aber andererseits
meine damen und herren zur fairness
gehört aber andererseits dass die
ehrlichen steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler
nicht geschädigt werden in dem
steuerhinterzieher davon kommen deshalb
deshalb werde ich die befähigungen zur
bekämpfung von finanzkriminalität weiter
ausbauen nicht steuern erhöhen sondern
steuer rechte durchsetzen
darum geht es mir
meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren wenn man uns also
fragt welchen zielen sich die
finanzpolitik der neuen bundesregierung
verpflichtet führt fühlt so ist die
antwort stabilität wachstum innovation
und fairness vielen dank
vielen dank herr minister war das hier
zum auftakt der debatte zum thema
haushalt und finanzen ja einiges hat er
angekündigt was jetzt direkt an steht
und man kann auch mal hinzufügen dass
sich der bundesfinanzminister in diesem
jahr ja gleich mit drei haushalten
beschäftigen muss nämlich dem
nachtragsetat 2021 den hat er
angesprochen aber auch der haushalt 2022
ist bisher noch vorläufig und 2023 das
wird dann im märz geschehen
alles gute wir stehen vor großen
herausforderungen
finanzpolitisch und haushaltspolitisch
und deswegen hat dieses land gute arbeit
gerade im finanzministerium verdient und
sie haben auch dinge angesprochen stehen
auch einige dinge in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag die wir durchaus
unterstützen etwa die vereinfachung des
steuersystems die digitalisierung der
prozesse sie wollen die ausgaben des
bundes auf den prüfstand stellen
umschichtung potenziale identifizieren
sie wollen die super abschreibungen aus
denen für klimathemen wir hatten das
schon für digitale wirtschaftsgüter
eingeführt das alles sind sinnvolle
punkte und ich sage ihnen sehr klar zu
darüber können sie mit der union in den
nächsten jahren konstruktiv reden das
werden wir konstruktiv begleiten
[Applaus]
insgesamt aber wenn man ihren
koalitionsvertrag studiert und sie haben
hier ja auch nur sehr zaghaft ein paar
punkte genannt muss man feststellen
steuerpolitisch beschränkt sich das auf
kleinteiliges eine steuerpolitische
agenda ein steuerpolitisches programm
hat diese bundesregierung leider nicht
tatsächlich
[Applaus]
tatsächlich ist ihr konzept stillstand
und der zaghafte wink oder der zaghafte
hinweis auf den baden-württembergischen
finanzminister der da vielleicht das ein
oder andere zu überlegen beginnt der ist
ja ganz reizvoll und nett das schätzen
wir auch aber das ersetzt natürlich
keine steuerpolitische agenda die sie
tatsächlich nicht haben dann machen sie
die ganze sache stellen sie dann aber
doch netter da indem sie ihnen dieses
jahr starten mit einem interview in dem
sie 30 milliarden entlastung für bürger
und unternehmen mit diesem land
ankündigen 30 milliarden wenn man sich
das genauer ansieht ist das nicht ganz
so mag ich und nicht ganz so toll die
beiträge zur rentenversicherung sollen
voll absetzbar gemacht werden dass es im
übrigen kein neues projekt schon die
alte regierung hatte das vorbereitet zu
machen dass auch nicht freiwillig weil
wir müssen das im grunde machen weil wir
haben hinweise des bundesfinanzhofs dazu
bekommen trotzdem ist die maßnahme gut
eeg umlage auch das ist richtig dass sie
die komplett abbauen wollen aber
ehrlicherweise muss man ja dazu sagen
die alte regierung hat hier schon
gehandelt und 40 prozent der eeg umlage
sind schon abgebaut das ist zum ersten
januar dieses jahres ja bereits in kraft
getreten und ehrlicherweise stehen den
entlastungen so eine richtige
nettoentlastung ist das ja nicht sondern
den stehen ja belastung gegenüber
nämlich die deutliche anhebung des co2
preise also für die meisten leute wird
sich das egalisieren vielleicht sogar zu
mehrbelastungen führen dritter punkt den
sie angesprochen haben dritter punkt den
sie angesprochen haben die wollen die
verlustverrechnung erweitern die im
nächst kann man das dann für weitere
zwei jahre machen aber wenn die
unternehmer dann gucken womit sie
verrechnen können sind dass die pandemie
jahre 2020 und 20 21 in den jahren
werden viele und dann nehmen wir gar
keine gewinne gemacht haben also zu
verrechnen wird es da effektiv nichts
geben eine entlastung ist das nicht so
sie haben eben gesagt steuererhöhungen
schließe sie aus steuererhöhungen wird
es nicht geben es gibt die de facto
schon die laufen schon munter an nämlich
durch die kalte progression durch die
preissteigerungen wie wir erfahren und
wir geht preissteigerung ist ja jetzt
jüngstes datum dezember bei 5,3 prozent
die ezb sagt für für dieses laufende
jahr 3,2 prozent voraus das frisst jede
lohnerhöhung auf und die
lohnsteigerungen führen ja dazu dass die
arbeitnehmer im steuertarif höher
wandern dass sie höher besteuert werden
andererseits verlieren sie durch die
inflation kaufkraft das heißt sie werden
doppelt getroffen das ist dieser brutale
effekt gleichzeitig kommt die steigerung
des co2 preises die steigerung der
energiepreise und noch steigende
beiträge bei den krankenversicherungen
dazu
sie haben sie haben gerade sie haben den
bundesbank-präsidenten erwähnt und haben
dabei bei der amtseinführung gesagt
niemand ist mehr auf stabile preise
angewiesen als menschen mit einem
kleinen einkommen für sie können schon
zahlenmäßig geringe preissteigerungen
den unterschied zwischen einem vollen
und einem leeren kühlschrank am
monatsende ausmachen genau darum geht es
und ein guter finanzminister würde jetzt
gegensteuern die bekämpfung der kalten
progression das war ihr thema sie haben
hier immer auch den tarif auf rädern
gefordert also den mitlaufenden tarif
mit der preisentwicklung der
schleichende steuererhöhungen verhindert
jetzt sehen sie tatenlos zu wie die
einkommen der kleinen leute von massiv
steigenden preisen aufgefressen werden
ich sage ihnen
[Musik]
ich sage ihnen steuerpolitisch ist das
kein guter start dieser regierung und
auch haushaltspolitisch nehmen sie die
bekenntnisse zur haushaltsdisziplin
ich lobe ausdrücklich das bekenntnis zum
stabilitätspakt in der eu das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen aber wir nehmen auch
das bekenntnis zur schuldenbremse durch
auswahl ab 20 23 wollen sie die wieder
einhalten aber was sie jetzt nicht so
deutlich sagen und nicht so laut sagen
ist dass sie bis dahin ganz massiv
schulden machen wollen sie wollen
schulden auf vorrat machen und sie sind
dabei auch nicht ehrlich sie sagen wir
brauchen das geld um die akute notlage
pandemie zu bewältigen tatsächlich
wollen sie die mittel aber nicht zur
pandemie bewältigung einsetzen sondern
für ganz andere zwecke und auch zu ganz
anderer zeit
der nachtragshaushalt gehen sie jetzt
vorgelegen vorgelegt haben steht leider
beispielhaft für diese praxis und dabei
geht es nicht um eine
verfassungsrechtliche petitesse sondern
es geht darum ob ihr bekenntnis zur
schuldenbremse zur verfassungsregel der
schuldenbremse wirklich ehrlich gemeint
ist der bundesrechnungshof hat in der
anhörung diese woche sich da sehr klar
ausgedrückt der einzige zweck dieses
nachtragshaushalt seine geldbeschaffung
für künftige nicht notlagen ausgelöste
maßnahmen also eine kreditermächtigung
auf vorrat die vorgesehene zuweisung
weiterer 60 milliarden an den fonds sei
mit wortlaut und zweck der schuldenregel
unvereinbar
klarer geht es leider und ich sage auch
leider klarer geht es leider nicht der
klimaschutz da haben sie völlig recht
ist ein kernanliegen der nachhaltigkeit
aber auch verantwortlich geführte
haushalte sind ein ganz grundlegendes
anliegen und eine grundlegende fragen
nachhaltiger
politik wir wollen und das sollten auch
sie wollen der jüngeren generation nicht
nur klimapolitisch ein gut bestelltes
feld hinterlassen sondern auch
finanziell noch die freiräume und die
gestaltungsräume die diese jüngeren
generationen beanspruchen dürfen
vor diesem hintergrund
bei diesem hintergrund sage ich ihnen
wir anerkennen die größe der
herausforderung denn die es wirklich
groß den klimawandel zu leisten und das
auch haushalterisch vernünftig
hinzukriegen trotzdem sage ich ihnen im
angesicht der verfassung auch im
angesicht der tatsache dass auch die
einhaltung des rechts eine frage der
nachhaltigkeit ist ziehen sie den
nachtragsetat den sie vorgelegt haben
bitte zurück und legen sie einen neuen
etat für dieses jahr vor mit ehrlichen
und zutreffenden zweckbestimmung und
dann können sie auch mit uns darüber
konstruktiv ins gespräch kommen und in
diesem sinne wünschen wir ihnen dann
alles gute und uns eine konstruktive
zusammenarbeit zwischen regierung und
opposition herzlichen dank
vielen dank dafür
mittelberg
mathias middelberg hat ja
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der csu gesprochen und natürlich auch
noch mal weniger betrieb haben
nachtragshaushalt formuliert und jetzt
hör mal für die spd fraktion den
finanzpolitisch nicht sicher michael
studie
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren sehr geehrter
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
ich gratuliere ihnen noch mal ganz
herzlich zu ihrem neuen wunderbaren amt
wir werden sie als spd
bundestagsfraktion als finanzpolitiker
in ihrer arbeit kollegial beizeiten auch
kritisch aber immer konstruktiv
begleiten und zusammen aber wir freuen
uns auf die gemeinsame zusammenarbeit
viel
haben einige finanz und
haushaltspolitische punkte hier genannt
die wichtigste die nächsten vier jahre
ich möchte es an drei punkten fest
machen was uns ebenfalls wichtig ist die
pandemie ist eine krise eine
gesundheitskrise aber auch eine
umfassende wirtschaftliche und soziale
krise eine notlage die wir nicht nur mit
impfungen sondern mit gezielten und
gleichzeitig großem finanziellen einsatz
bekämpfen müssen und auch werden bisher
haben cdu/csu dies aus
volkswirtschaftlicher vernunft und
pragmatismus mitgetragen jetzt in der
opposition soll das plötzlich falsch
seien jetzt in der opposition wollen sie
auf die konjunkturbremse treten mit all
die negativen folgen ausbleibende
investitionen
möglichen firmen bleiben verlust von
arbeitsplätzen es erinnert mich ein
wenig an bertolt brechts von der tütchen
dem versucht wird rissen am gemäuer mit
ein bisschen farbklecksen übermalen aber
ein paar farbeimer aus dem baumarkt
reicht in dieser krise nicht aus um
konjunkturelle risse zu kitten da müssen
auch viel und stahlbeton da müssten auch
halbleiter und schnelles internet da
müssen auch solaranlagen und die kunden
dazu kommen und dafür werden wir sorgen
denn nichts zu tun oder tünche zu
verteilen würde uns teuer zu stehen
kommt meine damen und herren
oder wie es zuletzt auch der ökonomien
zu dick um ausdrückte damit es nicht zu
ökonomischen longo weit kommt müssen
jetzt massiv investiert werden und
gleichzeitig ist diese
investitionsoffensive hat ja hinten
richtig gesagt ein wichtiger impuls für
die modernisierung und transformation
unserer wirtschaft und gesellschaft über
ziel im ergebnis das gegenteil von
wirtschaftlichem long comic wir stützen
unsere wirtschafts und machen sie
zukunftsfähig wir erhalten alte und
schaffen neue hoffentlich auch
tarifgebundene arbeitsplätze und wir
erhalten damit auch die steuereinnahmen
von morgen das ist solide
zukunftsgerichtete und
verfassungskonforme wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik weil er sehr geehrten
luzern
eine steuerliche maßnahme hat auch der
finanzminister schon gesagt mit dem wir
gezielt und schnell wirksam unternehmen
unterstützen wollen ist die
investitionspläne für klimaschutz und
digitale wirtschaftsgüter mit
umfangreichen abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
für unternehmen die jetzt in die zukunft
investieren wir haben aber auch die
kommunen im blick denn zwei drittel
aller investitionen in den kommunen
werden von diesen auch getätigt sie
brauchen also finanzielle spielraum ist
war es wichtig dass wir jetzt uns
vereinbart haben sie von ihren
altschulden zu entlassen entlasten und
beispielsweise noch stärker an aufkommen
aus windkraft- oder solaranlage zu
beteiligen und damit die kommunale
finanzausstattung zu stärken ist ein
wichtiges signal an die kommunale ebene
sehr geehrte damen und herren
[Applaus]
heute letzt ist so viele erzieher 100
transformation auch privates kapital
notwendig gebrauchen deshalb einen
leistungsstarken europäischen banken
kapitalmarkt wir wollen die banken nun
vollenden und die kapitalmarkt union
auch vertiefen aber das für uns so
wichtige drei säulen modell aus privaten
geschäftsbanken sparkassen und
genossenschaftsbanken erhalten und
zukunftsfest machen
zum zweiten
getreten und auch in unserem bereich für
mehr respekt für mehr gerechtigkeit und
sozialen zusammenhalt unserer
gesellschaft ja blind damit zu den blick
auf die einkommensteuer geformt haben
wir uns noch auf eine reform einigen
können das heißt aber nicht dass alles
so bleibt wie es ist im gegenteil wir
werden dafür sorgen dass die bürgerinnen
bürger finanziell entlastet werden das
untermauert das zentrum für europäische
wirtschaftsforschung diw in der
süddeutschen zeitung sagt ich darf sie
zitieren steht am meisten dürften jene
menschen von der neuen regierung haben
die am wenigsten haben bürger in
haushalten der höchstens 20.000 euro
brutto im jahr verdienen also grob den
aktuell mindestlohn bei vollzeit und
diese finanziellen entlastungen werden
bis weit in die mitte unserer
gesellschaft reichen und so auch die
ungleichheit in deutschland oder das zww
signifikant reduzieren das ist ein
wichtiges signal wir wollen soziale
zusammenhalt in unserem land stärken
süß entlastung tragen neben der erhöhung
des mindestlohns auch die eeg umlage in
den abbau auf beispielsweise verbesserte
abzugsmöglichkeiten bei den
rentenbeiträgen oder die erhöhung des
pauschbetrags hinzu und auch andere form
der kindergrundsicherung oder bzw
der steuerlichen kinderfreibetrags denn
wer hat bisher dazu geführt dass die
spitzeneinkommen am meisten profitiert
dann bis zu 100 euro höhere förderung
als die kinder erzieherinnen
kindergeldbezieher bisher in zukunft
sollen kinder aus familien mit niedrigen
und mittleren einkommen am stärkste
unterstützt werden endlich kann ich da
auch bloß sagen
[Applaus]
es geht aber auch um mehr respekt für
die grosse mehrheit der ehrlichen
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler herr
bundesminister das haben sie zu recht
auch erwähnen wir werden deshalb
steuerhinterziehung und schädliche
steuergestaltungen mit aller konsequenz
verfolgen und unterbinden deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir uns nach der
grenzüberschreitenden anzeigepflicht
auch auf eine nationale anzeigepflicht
für steuergestaltungen einigen konnten
und auch den umsatzsteuerbetrug wollen
wir bekämpfen beispielsweise durch ein
bundesweit einheitliches elektronisches
meldesystem mit dem wir zugleich die
digitalisierung der steuer kommunikation
voranbringen wollen über eines freue ich
mich natürlich besonders für das vom
vormaligen bundesfinanzminister olaf
scholz maßgeblich vorangetriebene
projekt der global mindestbesteuerung
liegt jetzt ein richtlinienvorschlag der
eu kommission vor noch bis sommer
beschlossen werden und dann zügig in
deutsches recht umgesetzt werden soll
all das sind wesentliche beiträge zu
mehr steuerehrlichkeit und fairen wert
das bedingungen und das ist gut so meine
sehr geehrten damen und
dritten steuern für das politik ist
keine trockene materie ist täglich für
menschen spürbare gesellschaftspolitik
in der pandemie erleben wir gerade jeden
tag wie wichtig solidarität und sozialer
zusammenhalt sind viele bürgerinnen und
bürger tragen die ihrer ehrenamtlichen
tätigkeit dazu bei dazu herzlichen danke
bewerten diese ehrenamtliche arbeit auch
in zukunft unterstützen so der
demokratische gesellschaft gehört aber
auch eine starke zivilgesellschaft die
sich für unterschied ist die belange
engagiert die diskussionen führt und
sich einsetzt vor etwas mehr als einem
jahr habe ich hier dieser stelle in
meiner rede zum jahressteuergesetz
verdeutlicht und auch versprochen dass
wir im nächsten jahr damals habe ich
gesagt er dem kanzler olaf scholz und
anderen
mehrheiten ein großes päckchen der
gemeinnützigkeit mit mehr
rechtssicherheit für die
zivilgesellschaft für eine
weihnachtsbaum legen wäre es ist nur ein
rot grün gelbes päckchen geworden oder
freut mich dass wir da klarstellen
werden dass sich zivilgesellschaft dass
sich gemeinnützige organisationen
natürlich auch im namen politisch
betätigen können ohne ihre gemeinsamkeit
zu gefährden sie stärken unsere
demokratie sehr engagiert sich in und
für unsere demokratie wir brauchen eine
starke zivilgesellschaft wenn es sehr
geehrte damen und herren
die produktion hat sich viel vorgenommen
unser land moderner unser land muss
gerechter zu machen ich lade sie alle
auf der opposition ein sich an diesen
großen aufgabe und ist total liegen
vielen dank vielen dank
bevor ich dem nächsten redner das wort
wert hat ein kleiner technischer hinweis
für die kollegen kollegen auf der
tribüne
da die redezeiten anzeige bei ihnen
nicht vorliegt werde ich mich akustisch
bemerkbar machen wenn ihre redezeit zu
ende geht also ein leichtes klopfen was
sie vernehmen bedeutet kommen sie bitte
zum schluss es wäre schön das zu
beachten sie können nichts dafür dass
sie keine uhr haben nächster redner ist
der kollege peter pühringer afg fraktion
herr präsident
guten morgen von hier oben nach unten in
den plenarsaal
ministerin sie haben eben die leitlinien
ihrer politik erläutert doch ist es
wirklich ihre eigene politik haben sie
auch als fdp politiker gesprochen oder
nur als handlanger einer grün roten
koalition in der sie eigentlich nur als
mehrheitsbeschaffer fungieren
von den fdp positionen vor der wahl ist
fast nichts übrig geblieben abschaffung
des soli leider nein entlastungen bei
der einkommenssteuer abgesagt einhaltung
der schuldenbremse nein stattdessen
lieber ein
verfassungswidriger nachtragshaushalt
übrigens zu 100 prozent schulden
finanziert das haben sie eben als
ernsthaft als generationen gerecht
bezeichnet
denn der etikettenschwindel der
ökosozialen marktwirtschaft hinter dem
sich einfach nur planwirtschaft unter
dem dogma der co2 ideologie verbirgt
deutschland hat bereits heute die
höchsten strompreise der welt
co2 emission bedeutet eine weitgehende
deindustrialisierung deutschlands mit
verheerenden folgen für arbeitsplätze
und wohlstand und auch die angeblichen
entlastungen sind mogelpackungen die
riesige eeg-umlage etwa wird nur pro
forma abgeschafft um sie dann über den
umweg haushalt beziehungsweise abgaben
sofort wieder zu ergeben was den bürgern
nach bürokratische umverteilung gegeben
wird wird ihnen hintenrum wieder
genommen freiheitlich
marktwirtschaftlich ist unter rot gelb
grünes klima diktat bald gar nichts mehr
noch mehr zwang zu windrädern noch mehr
wasserstoff utopien eine faktische
pflicht zu e autos ein verbot von öl
heizung und deutschland ist zudem das
einzige land weltweit das den wahnsinn
des gleichzeitigen ausstiegs aus kohle
und kernkraft betreibt während unsere
nachbarn den grünen atomstrom mit
moderner risiko freier technik ausbauen
schalten wir das bewährte ab und die
ampel findet im koalitionsvertrag
stattdessen einfach mal eben neue
zukunftsmärkte am ideologischen
reißbrett wie immer in der geschichte
muss und wird solch plan ideologischer
machbarkeitswahn scheitern
die aufgabe der marktwirtschaft der word
marktwirtschaft wird riesige kapital
mengen verlinkten sowie deutsche
unternehmen produktionskapazitäten und
am ende auch fähige bürger außer landes
treiben aber damit nicht genug der
unfreiheit beim thema bürgerrechte sieht
es nicht besser aus abschaffung der
zensur durch das netz tg nicht in sicht
ganz im gegenteil nein zum 12 plötzlich
trägt die fdp diesen sogar mit bei
medizinern schlägern soldaten und
polizisten war dass die allererste tat
der ampel schämen sie sich
und dann noch die unsägliche zweijährige
die uns zwingt hier von der tribüne aus
zu sprechen die nicht teil des
plenarsaals ist nur weil wir sie
millionen von ebenfalls diskriminierten
menschen auf unseren rechten artikel 2
grundgesetz auf körperliche
unversehrtheit bestehen wie sagte doch
die touristen
wie sagte guido westerwelle in seiner
abschiedsrede 2011 die freiheits
bedrohung deutschlands kommt leise daher
und bürokratisch so ist es und sie kommt
aus dem inneren der fdp vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege bürger
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin lisa
bündnis 90 die grünen und der böhringer
von der fdp-fraktion der hat ja von der
tribüne gesprochen einfach nochmal zur
erklärung wie sie vielleicht wissen im
plenarsaal ist ja zweige plus regel alle
die einen sozusagen die diese regeln
nicht erfüllen dürfen auf der bühne
fahrt teilnehmen sofern sie einen test
vorweisen können
manche haben
wir würden uns darüber zerlegen aber ich
finde wir finden das ergebnis kann sich
wirklich sehen lassen es ist solide und
ist es tragfähig meine damen und herren
denn wir sind unserem eigenen anspruch
gerecht geworden mit diesem haushalt mit
diesen leistungen die wir uns gegeben
haben werden wir das jahrzehnt der
investitionen in klimaschutz und
digitalisierung umsetzen und das ist das
was dieses land ganz ganz dringend
braucht
haben wir an mit der kfw die kfw wissen
wir macht seit vielen jahrzehnten ein
ganz entscheidender und wichtigen job in
deutschland gerade auch in der korona
pandemie hat sie ganz ganz vielen
unternehmen geholfen durch die krise zu
kommen wir werden die kfw-bank umbauen
zur transformation bank für das
jahrzehnt stellt klimaschutz und der
digitalisierung
deutschland wird mit diesen
koalitionsvertrag darauf haben wir dazu
haben wir uns bekannt zum führenden
standort von sustainable finance
ausgebaut zum thema nachhaltige finanzen
nachhaltiger finanzmarkt wir haben ein
gemeinsames verständnis davon dass das
thema klima nicht nur ein über wirkendes
thema ist für deutschland und für die
ganze welt sondern dass damit eben auch
massive finanzrisiken verbunden sind
klimarisiken sind finanzrisiken das ist
das verständnis dieser bundesregierung
und das ist gut so meine damen und
herren
das heißt irgendwie macht eine kluge und
vorausschauende finanzpolitik und
finanzmarktpolitik dazu passt leider
nicht der von der kommission vorgelegte
delegierte rechtsakte taxonomie atom und
gas sind keine dunkelgrüne technologie
sie haben ja taxonomie eigentlich nichts
zu suchen deswegen freue ich mich über
das klare nein zum atom von dieser
bundesregierung in der taxonomie
aber damit nicht genug die
bundesregierung wird weitermachen wird
ihrem programm zu bieten
wir werden die eigenen anlagen paris
kompatibel anlegen und auch die deutsche
exportfinanzierung wird auf den
prüfstand kommen damit wir auch
insgesamt international ausstrahlen wir
sind paris paris kompatibel mit allen
unseren finanziellen instrumenten meine
damen und herren
und ja wir werden den energie und
klimafonds um bauern zum klima und
transformations- fonds und werden die
rücklage erhöhen um die folgen der
pandemie und gleichzeitig bestehen und
risiken für die erholung der wirtschaft
damit abzufedern und damit eben auch uns
allgemein zukunftsfähig zu machen damit
so gut aus der krise kommen und nicht in
die nächste krise reinstolpern all das
müssen wir verhindern
beim thema umwelt schädliche
subventionen hätten wir grünen uns mehr
mut gewünscht aber auch dort wird es
schritte geben 5 milliarden euro werden
abgebaut an umweltschädlichen
subventionen in der bundesregierung wir
werden die lkw maut
reformieren und wir werden auch die
plastik abgabe verursachergerecht
einführen in deutschland und auch die
eeg umlage werden wir abschaffen um
tatsächlich da auch die klaren anreize
zu setzen das eben erneuerbare energie
günstig wird und der das problem was wir
haben nämlich die fossile energie dass
wir unabhängig werden von der fossilen
energie auch das zentraler baustein
dieser neuen bundesregierung
wir konnten uns nicht einigen auf mehr
steuergerechtigkeit darauf dass durch
steuermehreinnahmen von gutverdienern
wir uns bundestagsabgeordneten oder auch
anderen und einkommen entlastet werden
aber wir werden und auch das hat der
minister bereits gesagt gemeinsam
vorgehen gegen steuertricks und gegen
steuerbetrug und das heißt wir haben uns
vorgenommen eine internationale
vorreiterrolle einzunehmen im kampf in
diesem bereich das heißt wir
unterstützen die einführung einer
globalen mindestbesteuerung in dieser
bundesregierung wird es ihm zukünftig 15
prozent mindestbesteuerung für
unternehmen geben und das ist gut so
meine damen und herren
aber damit nicht genug es wird eine
anzeigepflicht für steuergestaltung
modelle auch für nationale geben wir
werden dafür sorgen dass große immobilie
konzern künftig grunderwerbsteuer auch
bei share deals zahlen müssen und auch
gegen den milliardenschweren
umsatzsteuerbetrug werden wir verstärkt
vorgehen insbesondere durch die
einführung eines rechnungssysteme und
gerade
um gerade in diesen tagen noch wo ist ja
weiterhin vor gerichten prozesse gibt zu
comics und auch untersuchungsausschüsse
laufen ist es noch mal wichtig zu
betonen dass diese bundesregierung
konsequent steuergelder aus comics und
geschäften zurück fordern wird uns alles
dafür tun wird dass ähnliche aktuell
noch mögliche geschäfte unterbunden
werden
auch die steuer soll regelmäßig
aktualisiert werden und der automatische
informationsaustausch erweitert und die
quellenbesteuerung ausgeweitet werden
die dinge haben wir auch im bereich der
geldwäsche vor auch das thema vor allem
der bankm union ist bereits mein kollege
schule gegangen und deswegen freue ich
mich ganz am schluss noch mal zu sagen
wir machen auch die notwendige
entlastung aber wir werden auch dafür
sorgen dass wir die gemeinnützigkeit
reformieren damit tatsächlich politische
betätigung und in deutschland recht
sicher auch in gemeinnützigen
organisation wieder gemacht werden kann
auch das ein ganz wichtiger punkt danke
die sabres die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90/die
grünen
und christian lindner hier auf der
regierungsbank kann jetzt einiges an
kritik erwarten wenn ich die nächste
rednerin so sehr geliebt von der alin
können die städte fraktionsvorsitz
vielen dank herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren zurzeit
erleben wir gleich drei globale krisen
gleichzeitig erstens die chorakademie
zweitens die klimakrise und beide krisen
verschärfen die dritte krise die
verteilungs krise und die muss endlich
überwunden werden
das vermögen konzentriert sich immer
stärker in den händen einer wenige
milliardäre die die welt unter sich
aufgeteilt haben in der bundesrepublik
besitzen die reichsten zehn prozent zwei
drittel des gesamten vermögens
45 deutsche besitzen soviel wie die
ärmere hälfte der bevölkerung dass es
zutiefst ungerecht und beschneidet
lebens chance meine damen und herren und
mehr noch und mehr noch die extreme
ungleichheit ist eine große gefahr für
die demokratie für die gesellschaftliche
entwicklung für den fortschritt und auch
deshalb muss überwunden werden wenn ein
baum und haben die lösung all dieser
krisen kostet viel geld und mut allein
die zusätzlichen staatlichen ausgaben
für den klimaschutz werden für den
zeitraum bis 20 30 auf jährlich 5
46 milliarden euro geschätzt sagt uns
die agora energiewende und ich sage
ihnen mit schuldenbremse und
steuergeschenke an reiche werden diese
krisen nicht zu lösen sein meine damen
und herren
und wir wissen doch alle oder sollten es
wissen das verfallsdatum der neoliberal
idee war spätestens mit der finanzkrise
2008 erreicht das darf nicht vergessen
werden wir haben in den vergangenen
monaten die alte regierung immer wieder
gefragt wem sollen die kosten der krise
aufgebürdet werden wir haben keine
antwort erhalten auch diese regierung
hat die öffentliche antwort auf diese
frage verweigert das nehmen wir nicht
hin
wir sagen ganz deutlich es darf nicht
sein dass die krisenkosten wieder bei
den armen und den menschen mit kleinen
und mittleren einkommen
abgeladen werden wie das schon bei den
kosten der finanzkrise war das ist nicht
zu akzeptieren
und alle fragen sich warum die fdp der
kleinste koalitionspartner die
koalitionsverhandlung für sich
entschieden hat kolleginnen und kollegen
von spd und grünen sie wissen doch
welchen immensen schaden die veralteten
neoliberalen ideologie in den letzten 20
jahren angerichtet haben und wir alle
und natürlich auch die grünen wissen die
klimakrise kann mit marktmechanismen
nicht bewältigt werden dafür braucht es
andere meine damen und herren das
resultat sagen wir doch jetzt schon an
dem stromzählern was tun sie denn gegen
die explosion der energiepreise
warum führen sie nicht wieder
preiskontrollen ein wo ist das
angekündigte klima geld hier muss
gehandelt werden und jeder der sehen
will sieht das marktversagen an allen
ecken und enden medikamentenmangel ist
marktversagen über globalisierung ist
ein drahtseilakt ohne netz und doppelten
boden und die pandemie hat uns allen
gezeigt das drahtseil kann reißen
lieferketten zerbröseln und dann stehen
wir ohne medikamente und schutzkleidung
warum frage ich sie haben wir kein netz
und keinen doppelten boden ich kann die
frage beantworten weil es zum
kapitalismus um hohe profite und
niedrige kosten geht und sicherheit ist
nur ein unliebsamer kostenfaktor und das
darf so nicht weitergehen meint haben
und eine verantwortungsvolle regierung
ist für die sicherheit in einem land
zuständig und soziale und
gesundheitliche sicherheit kostet nun
einmal geld denn sicherheit wird nicht
allein durch polizei und militär
garantiert das ist altes denken meine
damen und herren viele führende ökonomen
fordern eine gerechte verteilung von
vermögen in unserer gesellschaft wir
auch weil es der richtige weg ist lang
und herren wir brauchen das geld um eine
sichere zukunft zu investieren mit dem
nachtragshaushalt engländer haben sie
sich ein paar buchungstricks ausgedacht
aber das wird ihnen auf lange sicht
nicht helfen sie müssen farbe bekennen
wer die krisen bewältigen will der muss
endlich eine mutige gerechte
steuerreform durchsetzen und ihr als
linke fügen hinzu wir wollen eine
einmalige vermögensabgabe für millionäre
und multimillionäre
das wurde 0,7 prozent der bevölkerung in
unserem land betreffen und das ist doch
wirklich nicht zu viel verlangt meine
damen und herren
abschließend herr linder sie haben
diesen minister kollegen aufgerufen
sparsamer zu sein ich beginne gleich mit
dem vorschlag verzichten wir auch ein
neues wettrüsten wenn wir zwei prozent
des bruttoinlandsproduktes für rüstung
ausgeben gefährden wir die welt wir
müssen auf friedliche koexistenz
zwischen das ist fortschritt und dafür
stehen wir vielen dank mehr damen und
herren
frau kollegin dr
[Applaus]
und nun lauschen wir den worten des
kollegen christoph meyer fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
ich glaube auch in der debatte eben wohl
schon klar dass wir gemeinsam dass die
koalition zu beginn dieser
legislaturperiode vor erheblichen
herausforderungen steht wir müssen
dieses land durch die pandemie bringen
und wir müssen das land zukunftsfest und
zukunftsfähig machen und auf holen wo
wir den letzten jahrzehnte chancen
vertan haben und da lieber kollege
mittelberg finde ich die
begrifflichkeiten die sie gewählt haben
mit ehrlichkeit und stillstand doch
schon ein wenig merkwürdig
sie haben hier die eeg-umlage
angesprochen wer hat denn im letzten
jahrzehnt diese eeg-umlage in der form
so lange bewahrt das waren doch sie das
war eine cdu geführte koalition wer hat
denn die nach ihrer offensichtlich
mittlerweile auch erkenntnis die
verfassungswidrigen rentenbesteuerung so
lange so auf der ebene gehalten das
waren doch auch sie auch dafür sind sie
verantwortlich
sie beklagen hier ein co2 preis den ihre
koalition ihre vorgänger koalition
eingeführt hat wenn sie also über
stillstand und ehrlichkeit sprechen
sollten sie sich erstmal selbst ehrlich
machen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren von der koalition dann sind sie
vielleicht auch als seriöse opposition
ein partner für uns
was jetzt zu tun ist ist akute
krisenbekämpfung und wir stellen mittel
zur verfügung die notwendig sind zur
bekämpfung der caro ohne krise und
dieser zweite nachtragshaushalt und das
haben wir an diesem mittwoch noch mal im
haushaltsausschuss sehr deutlich gemacht
stellt dem egf in zukünftigen
transformations- von zweckgebundenen
mittel zur verfügung sie sind zeitlich
befristet kurz und mittelfristig und was
wir tun anders als die
vorgängerregierung ist dass wir
fokussieren auf einen kreis von ausgaben
und dass wir priorisieren nicht mit der
gießkanne wie es in der letzten der
ersten corona bekämpfung welle geschehen
ist sondern konkret da wo die baustellen
die sie diesem land hinterlassen haben
am größten sind
und wir verbinden das mit der
aktivierung von privaten kapital für
investitionen das stichwort
investitionspläne super abschreibung ist
bereits gefallen so kommt die wirtschaft
wieder auf die beine und ich bin dankbar
dass wir diesen koalitionsvertrag auch
die kraft karten klar zu sagen dass wir
alle ausgaben auf den prüfstand stellen
müssen gerade um zu priorisieren und
wenn wir ehrlich sind hatten wir dieses
thema hatten wir dieses problem der
ausufernden ausgaben auch schon vor
beginn der korona pandemie auch da
hatten sie damals schon nicht die kraft
auf grund der guten einnahmesituation
fällt auch nicht die notwendigkeit
gesehen dass wir uns die ausgaben
angucken das wird jetzt christian
lindner das wird jetzt diese koalition
nachholen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen diese
koalition hat sich sehr viel vorgenommen
und ich glaube wir sollten nicht in eine
aufregung eintreten welcher partner sich
wie in diesem koalitionsvertrag
durchgesetzt hat insgesamt ist es ein
solides ist es ein gutes dokument dieser
koalitionsvertrag auf dem wir die
nächsten vier jahre gemeinsam gestalten
werden und zentral wenn man die debatte
der letzten zwei tage letzten drei tage
verfolgt ist dass christian linder
erfolg hat als finanzminister um die
spielräume für all die anderen guten
themen die projekte die wir miteinander
vereinbart haben zu schaffen hier freue
ich mich auf die zusammenarbeit hiermit
neben der verantwortung für die zukunft
war und dafür danke ich ihnen und ich
freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit er
sagt christoph meyer hier für die
integration ja die ampel koalition will
nach der expertenkritik bei der anhörung
im haushaltsausschuss am vergangenen
montag ihre pläne für den
nachtragshaushalt 2021 nochmal
nachschärfen also der energie- und
klimafonds wo ja diese 60 milliarden hin
verschoben werden dieser soll klarere
vorgaben bekommen was mit dem geld
passieren soll also konkretisierte
verwendungszwecke beispielsweise die in
energieeffizienz und erneuerbare
energien im gebäudebereich und so weiter
liebe kolleginnen kollegen sehr geehrter
herr minister mit dem zitat
steuerentlastung von mehr als 30
milliarden euro wurden wir in dieses
jahr begrüßt und ja alle achtung ihre
marketing abteilung war 10 von 10
punkten verdient der titel auf der seite
der größten zeitung dieses landes hat
mit sicherheit ein druck gebracht aber
nur zwei tage lang denn ich danke allen
fachjournalisten in den tagen danach
sich auf den weg gemacht haben diesen 30
milliarden der herr zu spüren und völlig
begründet titel dann am nächsten tag des
handelsblatt sind als
taschenspielertrick oder die welt die
steuerschwindel ides christian lindner
die 30 milliarden mal kurz mit zahlen
unterlegt mathias middelberg hat auf die
fünf milliarden für die
rentenbesteuerung schon hingewiesen
daneben ist allein bei einer inflation
von 3 prozent die anhebung des
grundfreibetrags und des
kinderfreibetrags die
verfassungsrechtlich geboten sind mit 23
milliarden euro für diese
legislaturperiode zu finanzieren wir
sind dann bei 28 milliarden zu ihren 30
milliarden fehlen noch frei dann
verteilt auf vier jahre heißt dass ihr
gesamtes steuerpolitisches konzept für
diese legislaturperiode sich abspielt im
rahmen von 500 millionen euro pro jahr
sie haben zu recht in der bild zeitung
nicht näher ausgeführt was sie damit
machen wollen sie haben es heute
nachgeholt aber allein die beiden
maßnahmen home office pauschale und
pflege porsche alle kriegen sie aus
diesen 500 millionen nicht finanziert
und so wichtig diese maßnahmen für die
betroffenen sind wenn das das programm
das finanzpolitische programm für diese
legislaturperiode ist dann mache ich mir
deutlich sorgen
sie haben die ausweitung ist vermisst
die trucks angesprochen das ist ein
wichtige maßnahme aber wenn ich mir dann
angriffe was ihre nieren wahlprogramm
noch alles versprochen war von
abflachung des mittelstandsbauchs
wichtige maßnahme spitzensteuersatz nur
für spitzenverdiener würden wir sofort
unterstützen komplette abschaffung
solidaritätszuschlag an der sie ja sogar
den koalitionsvertrag mit uns haben
scheitern lassen dann haben all diesen
maßnahmen ist nicht in den
koalitionsvertrag geschafft auch nicht
geschafft in den koalitionsvertrag hat
ist der freibetrag für die
grunderwerbsteuer
stattdessen schmidt herdorf weil der
frage welche förderprogramme im
bundeshaushalt reduziert werden sollen
über das baukindergeld da die frist des
baukindergeld aber längst abgelaufen ist
können sie dann eine einsparung nur
erzielen wenn sie rückwirkend in die
fristen eingreifen und da kann ich ihnen
schon jetzt den diamanten widerstand
unserer fraktion ankündigen dass es mit
uns nicht zu machen lassen gegen den bau
kindergeld
als zweite massnahme wo sie geld aus dem
bundeshaushalt hernehmen wollen gibt es
im gleichen interview von herrn dr den
hinweisen wollte doch die aufgeblähte
bundesregierung verwaltung jetzt endlich
mal von personalkosten reduzieren
die haben nur bei der kommunikation ein
problem gemacht sie haben die erhöhung
ihrer 324 zusätzlichen stellen für die
regierung zwei tage vor diesem interview
öffentlich gemacht so dass bei n tv und
anderen zeitungen der einsparungs
vorschlag von herrn jürgen neben der
ausweitung der personalstellen steht und
ehrlich gesagt das kommt ein bisschen
blöd
wir haben angekündigt ein corona steuer
hilfe gesetzt ich hab ihn schon gesagt
bei den 30 milliarden haben sie dafür
überhaupt kein spiel mehr aber sie
können ja auch dinge tun die nicht so
teuer sind sie hätten die fristen für
steuerberater verlängern können das
kündigen sie jetzt für ico nachsteuer
hilfe gesetz an wenn ich mal hochrechnen
wie lang eine gesetzgebung suisse
braucht dann sind wir drei monate weiter
minimum dann ist die alte frist schon
fast abgelaufen dann können sie sich das
auch sparen sie haben gestern gestern
die frist ablaufen lassen für die eu
taxonomie die reguläre frist wo sie uns
heute hätten sagen können wie sie auf
dauer verhindern wollen dass eu
fördermitteln demnächst in
atomkraftwerke gehen die kollegen von
den grünen haben sie darauf hingewiesen
nichts haben sie in ihrer rede dazu
gesagt sie haben sehr oberflächlich sie
sich zur vollendung der banken union
bekannt auch das steht in diesem sommer
an ich wüsste sehr gerne wie sie die
staatsanleihen unterlegung mit
risikokapital in der eu durchsetzen
wollen allein der satz wir vollenden die
banken union ist ziemlich oberflächlich
für ein minister in dieser
legislaturperiode
ich bin sehr gespannt ich bin sehr
gespannt ob sie unsere einladung in die
finanzausschuss annehmen das müsste sehr
bald passieren denn dieses thema ist uns
wichtig wir wollen die einlagen der
sparer gesichert haben und da ist eine
risikoreduzierung in den bankenbilanzen
auf jeden fall erforderlich
kindergrundsicherung ich gebe zu und ich
meine kollegin lisa paus weiß dass das
ich das für ein gutes projekt halte aber
eine kindergrundsicherung wo sie bei
finanzschwächeren eltern geld drauflegen
wollen geht nur mit haushaltsgeld in den
30 milliarden die sie erwähnt haben ist
aber kein einziger euro dafür übrig das
heißt sie können schwachen wo dann
begünstigen wenn sie besser verdienen
das wegnehmen und auch das ist nicht
unsere vorstellung von familienförderung
das werden wir ihnen nicht durchgehen
lassen letzte zahl kalte progression
das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung
hat ausgerechnet dass die kalte
progression bis 2025 30 milliarden euro
ausmacht hoppla da ist die 30 milliarden
wieder sie haben sich einfach vertan
sind meinten nicht entlassen sondern
belastung auch das werden wir ihnen
nicht durchgehen lassen ich freue mich
sehr auf die diskussionen vielen dank
frau billigend immer an titeln man die
finanzpolitische sprecherin der cdu csu
fraktion hat noch einige fragen an den
bundesfinanzminister aber wir sind ja
auch am anfang der legislatur und
da wird es noch häufiger ein
aufeinandertreffen geben denn es wurde
jetzt für die spd
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die lage in der wir diese debatte führen
das nicht vergleichbar mit der debatten
lage zurück in der letzten oder gar der
vorletzten legislaturperiode hatten wir
zu diesem zeitpunkt immer ein starkes
wirtschaftswachstum große
steuereinnahmen keine krise hatten wir
eine situation in der wir investieren
konnten in die äußere in die innere und
in die soziale sicherheit dieses staates
stellt sich die situation heute anders
da aber ich will noch mal deutlich
machen dass das was wir auch in den
letzten acht jahren gemacht haben
nämlich insbesondere die soziale
sicherheit in diesen stark die sozialen
netze zu stärken der grundstein dafür
ist dass wir heute als gesellschaft
geschlossen in dieser krise dastehen mit
einigen wenigen ausnahmen und ich glaube
das ist auch verdienst der politik der
letzten acht jahren und heute
heute setzen wir dort an indem wir große
vorsorge titel haben indem wir eine
zentrale botschaft aussenden die
zentralste botschaft vielleicht der
haushaltspolitik dieser
legislaturperiode in der pandemie wir
werden ob es bei gesundheitsfragen oder
bei wirtschaftsfragen ist kein in diesem
land zurück lassen es wird nicht am geld
scheitern wir werden den menschen auch
durch die weiteren wochen und monate
dieser krise helfen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und wir wollen und wir diskutieren ja in
der nächsten sitzungswoche nochmal den
nachtragshaushalt wir wollen nicht nur
kurzfristig wirksame maßnahmen ergreifen
sondern wir wollen diese krise
langfristig dauerhaft nachhaltig beenden
wir wollen die transformation dieses
landes hin zur co2 neutralität
anschieben und das ist auch einer der
schwerpunkte der haushaltspolitik in
dieser legislaturperiode
und wir haben uns vorgenommen wir wollen
20 23 wieder die verfassungsgemäße
schuldenbremse einhalten wir wollen 20
23 nicht noch einmal die
außergewöhnliche notsituation
feststellen ich will mal deutlich machen
dass ist nicht allein eine finanz oder
haushaltspolitische zielstellung das ist
ein gesellschaftspolitisches ziel was
wir haben wollen weil das bedeutet
nämlich dass wir nicht mehr in einer
außergewöhnlichen notsituationen sind
das bedeutet nämlich dass die art und
weise wie wir leben und wirtschaften
nicht mehr nachhaltig eingeschränkt ist
und ich finde das sollte unser aller
ziel sein liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
habe gerade gesagt wir werden große
investitionspakete schnüren um diese
krise nachhaltig zu überlassen und das
ist auch uns sozialdemokraten besonders
wichtig wir haben im wahlkampf immer
gesagt wenn wir jetzt anfangen gegen
diese krise anzusparen machen wir es
noch schlimmer dieser staat braucht
handlungsmöglichkeiten un zu sagen man
kann keine neuen schulden machen und man
macht bei der einnahme situation nichts
das hätte dazu geführt dass ist so der
wahrscheinlich größten streichungen im
bundeshaushalt aller zeiten geführt
hätte und das hätte den wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung in diesem land ab gedrosselt
dagegen haben wir uns immer gewehrt und
dieser koalitionsvertrag ist ein
bekenntnis zu investitionen und zum
nachhaltigen wachstum und das begrüßen
wir sehr
und wir haben auch
in den verhandlungen zum
koalitionsvertrag nicht nur an unsere
staatlichen ebene gedacht denn gerade
wenn wir über investitions investitionen
reden wissen wir ja dass große
investitionen kommt nicht vom bund bei
den staatlichen kommt nicht vom land
sondern das gros der staatlichen
investitionen findet auf der kommunalen
ebene statt und wir haben kommunen die
sind übrigens meistens unverschuldet
weil sie einen erheblichen
strukturwandel zu schultern hatten in
einer situation dass sie so überschuldet
sind dass sie keine möglichkeit zum
investieren mehr haben das ist ebenfalls
eine große investitions und
nachhaltigkeits bremsen deshalb haben
wir uns vorgenommen eine alte
schuldenregel für diese kommunen auf den
weg zu bringen und ich appelliere an die
bundesländer die massiv betroffen sind
insbesondere auch in nrw gehen sie den
weg dieser bundesregierung mit ergibt
hat kommunen handlungsmöglichkeiten und
stärkt diesen staat
vielen dank herr königerode
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
der präsident vielen dank
das hatte der bundestags vizepräsident
wolfgang kubicki
hat das versucht hier auf seine art dass
die regeln eingehalten werden
nächster redner kollege kai gottschalk
afg fraktion ja damals wurde von der spd
doch etwas perplex vielleicht wollte er
noch einen letzten satz sagen jetzt hat
arbeitet als nächste erster deutscher
täglich am ende aber lassen sie mich
eingangs sagen habe ich von den cast
gelernt man dafür gesellschaftspolitisch
reden was für ein trauriges
mittelmäßiges sittengemälde geben sie
hier in dieser debatte ab angefangen von
cdu 16 jahre regierungsverantwortung mit
der spd und von den linken will ich ja
gar nicht sprechen an dieser stelle
meine damen und herren der lindner
klasse hier verkündet haben ist nichts
anderes als der fünfjahresplan einer
ökologisch sozialistischen
planwirtschaft das hatten wir schon mal
in der ddr und das ist an die wand
gefallen meine damen und herren
und ich hatte eigentlich wenigstens kopf
dass dieser ampel
ungefähr 16 jahre trümmer der ihrer
merkel beiseite und sich sozusagen der
trümmerfrau merkel wobei man da den
trümmerfrauen in deutschland nicht
gerecht wird denn die haben dieses land
aufgebaut frau merkel und das sieht man
heute sie haben dieses land wirklich wie
montiert und filetiert und herr scholz
ihre spd hat im zurückliegenden
wahlkampf
mit dem plakat respekt für dich geworben
wo ist eigentlich der respekt der
bundeskanzler und herr lindner für die
millionen von ungeimpften in diesem land
sie sprechen nicht von spaltung sitzen
sie vielleicht schon den kanzler
nehmen sie die realität noch zur
kenntnis was da draußen los ist nein ich
glaube nicht und genauso ist es mit
ihrer finanz- wirtschafts- und
steuerpolitik r lindner sie verraten
alle grundsätze der liberalen partei wie
sie einmal waren kommen wir aber zu
einigen inhalten sie sprachen in ihrer
rede eben im kern hätte der
stabilitätspakt funktioniert meine damen
und herren wir erleben seit 16 jahren
unerwarteten rechtsbruch der
vorgängerregierung und sie schaffen es
nach einem monat mit dem 60 milliarden
nachtragshaushalt denen sie umwidmen
hier einen rechtsbruch zu vergeben wo
was wir hatten
angefangen mit der rechtswidrigen euro
rettungspolitik übrigens sie beklagen
die inflation ja die ezb kann nicht
reagieren weil sie die deutsche wieder
staaten des südens finanzieren muss wenn
wir nämlich jetzt zinserhöhung vornehmen
würden was würde damit italien was würde
dann entschuldigung das würde damit
italien was würde sagen dass es völlig
egal was würde mit italien das würde mit
frankreich was wurde mit portugal das
würde mit spanien und ihren
staatshaushalten pro passieren wo sie
sprechen im kern hat funktioniert
italien hat mittlerweile eine
staatsverschuldung von 144 frankreich
von 115 galoppiert nach oben das ziel
war 60 wo funktioniert denn da der
stabilitätspakt im kern klar wovon
träumen sie
was sie hier wirklich abliefern ist
rechtsbruch rechtsbruch rechtsbruch aber
keinen aufbruch herr lindner wahrlich
nicht und sie sprachen meine damen und
herren davon dass sie das gespenst der
inflation vertreiben wollen ein sie
haben es alle zusammen hier auf den
klang geworfen und das bedeutet
galoppierende inflation
niedrige zinsen oder negativzinsen wir
sind nichts anderes als die nackte
enteignung von sparern und der kollege
von der cdu hat die rentner vergessen
und geringverdienern und dafür sind sie
alle von cdu angefangen bis am ende der
grünen und der spd hier verantwortlich
sie saß und 16 jahre in der regierung
und waschen nicht mit einem monat
opposition und klugen teilweise auch
mittelmäßigen sprechen frei sie tragen
genauso verantwortung an dem was wir in
diesem lande gerade erleben meine damen
und herren ich
möchte aber auch sagen
und sie haben es ja dann einfach nur
kopiert als ich den antrag mit meiner
fraktion eingebracht habe sie haben es
erwähnt die fdp fraktion wird ihre
ehrlichkeit messen liebe kollegen von
der cdu wir werden den tarif auf rädern
ein zweites mal hier im plenum
einbringen um tatsächlich unabhängig vom
gutdünken und der gnade unseres
finanzministers lindner und anderer
politiker die menschen tatsächlich
anhand des tarif auf rädern zur
entlastung meine damen und herren von
der cdu sie sind herzlich eingeladen
dann ihren worten auch taten folgen zu
lassen ob sie wirklich gute anträge die
auch vom bund der steuerzahler kommen
mit gehen legen sie endlich ihre hier
aufgeführte ablehnung von guten
antrieben unserer fraktion beiseite wir
werden sie an ihr kommt es nicht an
ihren worten und wirtschaft müssen
unabhängig aber die hat ein ende sie
müssen zum schluss kommt da einiges
betrags war es nicht da komme ich zum
schluss und wünsche diesem land viel
viel glück mit dieser regierung unser
land wird es brauchen denn das ist kein
guter ausblick was sie heute abgeliefert
haben meine damen und herren vielen dank
fürs protokoll das waren 44 sekunden
über die redezeit so
mit ihnen gar nicht diskutiert die
wollen wir darauf hinweisen sie an die
redezeit deutlich überschritten noch
einmal wenn das jeder redner machen wird
unabhängig von ihnen dann haben wir
heute noch eine nachtsitzung die nächste
rednerin ist die kollegin katharina beck
bündnis 90 die grünen
von katharina ist die finanzpolitische
sprecherin der grünen
[Applaus]
darf ich kurz ich muss einmal kurz meine
maske so jetzt bitte erst die zeit die
liebe des lebens liebe kolleginnen
kollegen liebe bürgerinnen und bürger
und lieber herr bundesminister lindner
in ihrer antrittsrede auch schon haben
sie das bmf ihr haus als ermöglichung
ministerium bezeichnet und das gefällt
mir wirklich sehr gut denn genau so sehe
ich es geld und finanzen das sind mittel
zur gestaltung
das war das was wir als andere gestalten
wollen das ist klar eine zukunft raus
aus den fossilen zeitalter in ein neues
zeitalter der erneuerbaren für einen
aufbruch in einen neuen industriellen
wohlstand mehr frieden und zusammenhalt
in deutschland europa und weltweit
und was mir mit meiner rede heute ein
besonderes anliegen ist lassen sie uns
auch im rahmen des neuen vorschlags der
eu-kommission zur taxonomie für
nachhaltige investments für diese für
unsere positive zukunft einsetzen denn
dort werden absurderweise
die alten energie vom atom- und
übergangsweise auch gas als nachhaltig
gelabelt als ob sie teil der positiven
zukunft wären die wir gestalten wollen
und ich bin heilfroh dass deutschland
klar gegen atom ist aus drei gründen die
hier wohl noch einmal genannt werden
müssen erstens physische unsicherheit
tschernobyl fukushima und selbst in
frankreich mussten im dezember 2021 vier
reaktoren der modernsten generation aus
sicherheitsgründen abgeschaltet werden
zweitens generationengerechtigkeit
wie wollen wir den radioaktiven müll für
jahrtausende den kommenden generationen
aufbürden und drittens
unwirtschaftlich ist atomenergie auch
sie ist deutlich teurer als erneuerbare
selbst ohne die atome kosten ein zu
rechnen und auch dass kein privater
versicherer vollen haftung gehen wir das
zeigt dass es sich ihr zitat herr
lindner nicht um eine nachhaltig
verantwortbare energiequelle handeln
kann und
wird ziemlich der taxonomie es ist
absurd den kapitalmärkten jetzt sagen zu
wollen das atom dieses fossil aus der
vergangenheit nun die zukunft unserer
gesellschaft mitgestalten soll die lust
auf grüne investments ist enorm ich
bringe 14 jahre praxiserfahrung in
wirtschaft und finanzen mit und da
draußen sind laut bloomberg intelligence
geschätzt 53 billionen dollar das ist
mehr als ein drittel des gesamten
privaten anlagevermögens die bis 2025 in
nachhaltigkeit investiert werden wollen
doch sie wollen wirklich grüne
investments und kein greenwashing
diverse große kapitalmarkt akteurinnen
wie auch deutsche unternehmen wie
allianz oder munich re haben daher
mehreren offenen briefen die eu
kommission aufgefordert verwässert uns
die grünen taxonomie nicht denn
kapitalmarkt akteure können risiken
berechnen und atom und fossile sind
nicht die zukunft
die zukunft rendite sie liegt in den
erneuerbaren einfache und klare regeln
das will der kapitalmarkt und keine
hintertüren und verbesserungen und auch
für kleinanleger in wäre ein solches nur
vermeintlich grüne siegel einfach eine
täuschung und was neben einem guten
grünen label er gefehlt hat bisher das
ist ein ausreichender umfang an
zukunftsfähigen investitionsprojekten
die gute nachricht
das ändern wir jetzt mit dem von robert
habeck vorgelegten klimaschutz
sofortprogramm das ist ein startschuss
für tausende wirklich grüne industrie
projekte die sich über nachhaltige
investments sehr freuen werden
und nun möchte ich mit einer einladung
enden denn wir als ampel möchten
deutschland bei sustainable finance zum
führenden standort machen lassen sie uns
diesen eigentlich sehr guten
marktmechanismus taxonomie retten und
gemeinsam zum erfolg machen selbst das
französische staatliche label green
schließt atomenergie aus also lassen sie
uns unseren führungsanspruch nun
realität werden lassen deutschland diese
regierung wir haben doch gewicht in
europa und daher möchte ich sie bitten
das ganze gewicht deutschlands in europa
ein zu bringen lassen sie es uns
versuchen liebe kollegin hier im hause
und ich gucke sie alle an sprechen sie
mit ihren abgeordneten kolleginnen im
eu-parlament um dort ausreichend stimmen
gegen den kommissionsvorschlag zu
organisieren und liebe minister/innen
bitte nutzen sie ihre minister innen
runden mit ihren eu-kollegen um
vielleicht doch noch weitere staaten zu
einem nein zu bewegen das
finanzministerium ist ermöglichung
ministerium und wir können ermöglichung
land und regierung sein lassen sie es
uns sagen herzlichen dank die autorin
hat hier geschlossen noch mal zu den
umstrittenen plänen der eu-kommission
gas und atomkraft als umweltfreundlich
einzustufen weil das war mit der
taxonomie genannt will er die kommission
fest in welche geldanlage als
klimafreundlich gelten sollen um die
klimawende voranzubringen
die grünen lehnen das ab die
bundesregierung musste
verschoben worden bis zu der die
mitgliedstaaten ihr votum abgeben müssen
das wird in der nächsten woche dann der
fall sein
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren bei einer
generalaussprache zu den bereichen
haushalt und finanzen dürfen natürlich
die belange der kommunen die
auswirkungen die finanziellen
auswirkungen auf die kommunen nicht
fehlen ehrlicherweise spielten wie
kommunen in der bisherigen debatte genau
einmal eine rolle der kollege schrodi
hat es einmal erwähnt
der kollege schrodi hat es ziemlich
ausführlich erwähnt
denn wenngleich ich die interpretation
etwas anders vornehmen würde
die ziele im koalitionsvertrag hör ich
wohl und lese ich wohl sie streben
leistungsfähig kommunen mit einer mit
einem hohen maß an entscheidungsfreiheit
an dadurch werden natürlich viele
chancen hoffnungen und erwartungen
geweckt aber ehrlicherweise es keine
einzige dieser maßnahme finanziell
hinterlegt und das macht mir natürlich
große sorgen die kommunen müssen
finanziell leistungsfähig sein und sie
sollen möglichst selbstständig sein und
ich glaube bei all den herausforderungen
die vor uns liegen kann man sagen dass
diese ganzen maßnahmen nur mit den
kommunen umgesetzt werden können oder
gar nicht und meine große sorge ist dass
anspruch und wirklichkeit hier weit
auseinander gehen werden denn jetzt
schon sind finanzielle mehrbelastung
erkennbar die auf die kommunen zukommen
die sind auch gar nicht mehr zu
diskutieren als beispiel die finanzielle
mehrbelastung bei der integration von
flüchtlingen oder bei der ausgebauten
oder weiter auszubauen denn
kinderbetreuung und ich werde wenige
beispiele nennen wo meine sorge
vielleicht verstärkt wird dass die
kommunen eher geschwächt denn gestärkt
werden wenn das koalitionsprogramm so
umgesetzt wird erstens förderprogramme
sollen fortgesetzt wenn nicht sogar
ausgeweitet werden das hört sich erst
mal gut dann aber am ende ist es ein
süßes gift für die kommunen denn die
schere zwischen strukturstarken und
strukturschwachen kommunen wird sich
eher vergrößern denn verkleinern warum
arme kommunen können die kofinanzierung
zum teil gar nicht mehr stemmen bei den
förderprogrammen die initialisiert
werden und vor allen dingen sie haben
noch nicht mal die kapazitäten weder
zeitlich noch personell solche
zusätzlichen programme zu stemmen aber
insbesondere
wirkt die förderprogramme immer nur
befristet und nicht strukturell und
deswegen würde ich mir sehr wünschen
herr finanzminister wenn sie die
finanzielle leistungsfähigkeit der
kommunen dadurch stärken dass wir
endlich eine strukturelle diskussionen
führen wie wir gerecht die lasten
verteilen dazu gehören aber bund länder
und kommunen an einen tisch denn wir
dürfen nie vergessen dass für die
auskömmliche finanzausstattung der
kommunen zu fördern die länder
verantwortlich
und hier würde ich mir eine
federführende rolle durch sie wünschen
aber das werde ich mehrmals noch
anmerken und sicherlich in zukunft daran
erinnern zweitens die koalition plant
eine enge kooperation zwischen bund
ländern und kommunen das hört sich gut
an aber hier droht nichts anderes als
weitere vorgaben des bundes in bereichen
für die der bund gar nicht zuständig ist
und das ist aus meiner sicht misstrauen
gegenüber den kommunen und die teilweise
abkehr von der subsidiarität und der
vielfalt die unser land erst mal stark
gemacht haben und deshalb schaffen sie
klare zuständigkeiten und damit die
entscheidungsfreiheit bei den kommunen
und drehen sie nicht durch mischen
zuständigkeiten ergebnisse früherer
föderalismusreform zurück die kollegen
sind inzwischen fragen aus der spd
fraktion nein ich möchte gerne
fortsetzen
drittens sie verabschieden sich von dem
eigenen ziel der konnexität bevor die
eigentliche arbeit beginnt denn sie
schreiben laut koalitionsvertrag bei
neuen aufgaben die der bund auf andere
ebenen übertragen will wird auf die
ausgewogenheit der finanzierung stärker
geachtet damit wird ehrlicherweise eine
finanziell fragwürdige arbeit
fortgesetzt denn wir haben schon gesetze
aus spd geführten häusern in der letzten
legislaturperiode gehabt wo anspruch und
wirklichkeit in der kostenkalkulation
deutlich auseinander gegangen sind das
gute angehörigen entlastungsgesetz die
belastungen sind am ende viel höher
gehen der praxis ankommen als vorher
kalkuliert und der rechtsanspruch auf
die ganztagsbetreuung im grundschulalter
er sogar im vermittlungsausschuss
verfahren nachgebessert werden muss also
unterschied zwischen theorie und praxis
da achten sie in zukunft bitte darauf
dass wohl formulierte ziel höre ich
schon ich sehe nur große sorgen und
risiken für die zukunft deshalb wenn wir
sie gerne auf den richtigen weg
begleiten sollen dann kommen sie auf uns
zu wir werden das konstruktiv zu vielen
dank fürs freundliche zu hören vielen
dank herr
kollege rudi nun kommt eine erste seele
ich komme noch zwei weitere erste sehen
dann aus der spd fraktion
für ihre erste rede klang wird als bei
uns geht ja grundsätzlich rufe auf und
dann kommen sie nicht so aber
nächste rednerin für ihre erste rede ist
die kollegen dankbar anderes spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident ich bitte
vielmals um entschuldigung
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen fraktionen sehr geehrter
herr bundesminister der finanzen
ihnen herr minister lindner gratuliere
ich herzlich zum neuen amt und ich danke
ihnen für den ausführlichen ausblick
eben auf unser gemeinsames
arbeitsprogramm der nächsten jahre ich
freue mich ganz besonders darüber dass
auch das uhr sozialdemokratische thema
steuern aktiv angepackt wird dazu wurde
schon viel gesagt einige punkte möchte
ich gerne vertiefen auch wenn steuern im
ersten moment immer nicht besonders sexy
klingt muss man sagen steuern sind was
positives sie verteilen die kosten
unserer gesamtgesellschaftlichen
verantwortung gerecht auf alle
negativ was schlechtes sind steuerbetrug
steuerhinterziehung aggressive
steuergestaltung und deshalb freue ich
mich dass wir im koalitionsvertrag
übereinstimmung darin erzielen konnten
dass wir den dreiklang umsetzen wollen
aus steuerentlastungen für kleine und
mittlere einkommen
steuerersparnis für unternehmen durch
investitionen und
nicht nur der sowieso schon illegalen im
illegalen steuerbetrug und der
steuerhinterziehung den kampf anzusagen
sondern eben auch der bisher noch legale
aber eben nicht legitimen
steuergestaltung und das liebe cdu ist
absolut nicht kleinteilig so sichern wir
so sichern wir steuereinnahmen
steuergerechtigkeit und einen soliden
haushalt im einzelnen erstens
steuerliche entlastungen für kleine und
mittlere einkommen
die rentenversicherungsbeiträge werden
wir schon früher als ursprünglich
geplant
vollständig steuerfrei stellen wir
werden den steuerpflichtigen teil der
renteneinkünfte anders als bisher
jährlich nur um einen halben
prozentpunkt steigern und daraus folgt
dass die vollständige besteuerung der
rente eben nicht schon 2040 sondern erst
ab 20 60 anfällt home office pauschale
für arbeitnehmer innen werden wir
verlängern den ausbildungsfreibetrag
werden wir erhöhen und die
familienbesteuerung weiterentwickeln das
thema kalte progression liebe cdu was
immer gerne als argument für
steuersenkungen angeführt wird schauen
sie sich doch die letzten 30 jahre mal
rückwirkend an die kalte progression
wurde da mehr als kompensiert durch
tarifsenkung
zweitens steuer ersparnis für
unternehmen durch investitionen wir
wollen dass die 20 20er jahre das
jahrzehnt starker zukunftsinvestitionen
werden und wer in die zukunft
investieren will der muss in der
gegenwart vorfinanzieren wir wollen das
unternehmen insbesondere in klimaschutz
und digitalisierung investieren also
super abschreibung oder eben verkürzt
wenn unternehmen in digitalisierung und
oder klimaschutz investieren werden sie
steuern sparen und ausgeben werden wir
zusätzlich die möglichkeit der
erweiterten verlustverrechnung
verlängern und den möglichen verlust
rückschlag auf die zwei vorangegangene
veranlagungszeiträume
ausweiten und liebe cdu auch da sparen
die unternehmenssteuern wenn sie gewinne
erzielt haben und die werden ihre kritik
nicht gut finden drittens
steuergestaltung und steuerbetrug
vermeiden mit erlaubnis des präsidenten
möchte ich den allseits bekannten nova
profitieren
briefkastenfirmen haben nur eine
berechtigung wenn sie briefkästen
herstellen
deutschland wird eine vorreiterrolle
übernehmen bei der bekämpfung von
aggressiver steuergestaltung die von
olaf scholz auf den weg gebrachte
globale mindeststeuer besteuerung für
großunternehmen werden wir zügig
umsetzen wir werden die betrugs
anfälligkeit bei der mehrwertsteuer
bekämpfen sowohl durch eine
registrierkasse pflicht als auch durch
ein bundesweites elektronisches
meldesystem für die erstellung prüfung
und weiterleitung von rechnungen
können abgeführten umsatzsteuer und
verrechnete vor steuern nicht mehr
voneinander abweichen
wir werden die geldwäsche bekämpfen und
zwar durch grundsätzliche ausweitung des
informationsaustauschs und dadurch dass
immobilien nicht mehr bezahlt werden
können brötchen beim bäcker um die ecke
werden zunehmend digital bezahlt während
auf der anderen seite immobilien für
mehrere millionen euro bisher immer noch
mit dem bargeld aus dem klassischen
bezahlt werden können und das ist nicht
korrekt leer sein geld auf ehrliche art
und weise verdient und korrekt
versteuert und wer auf korrekte
grunderwerbssteuer zu handeln der hat
auch kein problem damit zukünftig beim
immobilienerwerb den kaufpreis eben
nicht in bar zu zahlen und ich komme zum
ende mein vater sitzt da ich ein großer
fan von steuergerechtigkeit bin ich
ebenfalls ein fan unseres
koalitionsvertrages mit dem wir mehr
fortschritt und mehr gerechtigkeit wagen
und ich freue mich sehr auf die arbeit
mit den kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen fraktionen im
finanzausschuss dankeschön
vielen dank frau kündigen anderes
sag mal andere ist mit ihrer ersten rede
aus nordrhein westfalen kommt sie und
ist über die landesliste eingezogen
und jetzt
hören wir albrecht glaser für die afd
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren mehr fortschritt soll
es im lande geben was ist das und wie
soll das gehen die koalition will einen
europäischen staat und damit die
auflösung der nationalstaatlichen
demokratie
hier in diesem reichstag mit einem
regierungspräsidium eingerichtet dass
die politik einer oligarchie aus brüssel
exekutiert bei in dem thema taxonomie
haben sie einen kleinen vorgeschmack
dazu zu finanzen staatsschulden und
währungen gibt es im vertrag nicht
einmal ein unterabschnitt whatever it
takes ist offensichtlich der schwerpunkt
der chor zu deutsch geld spielt keine
rolle
soll die finanzkrise 2008 war eine
staatsschuldenkrise mit zwei billionen
würde der gesamtstaat mit einer billion
davon der bund verschuldet die höchsten
schulden seit der staatsgründung der
bunter zeit in nichts getilgt die carola
krise ist der anlass in den jahren 20
bis 22 den vorhandenen schuldenstand um
470 milliarden also fast um 50 prozent
zu erhöhen dazu kommen noch 4 90
millionen als tilgungs last vorwiegend
für schulden anderer eu staaten ein
manifester verstoß gegen die eu-verträge
die extreme verschuldung wird begleitet
von der höchsten inflation seit 1990
einer kaputten gemeinschaftswährung die
nicht einmal ein schatten der d-mark ist
die ezb gebäude das ezb gebäude ist
deshalb so groß damit man die über vier
billionen angekauften staatsanleihen
dort aufbewahren kann
ebenfalls einmal die fenster verstoß
gegen die eu-verträge die bürger in
deutschland werden durch diese inflation
jährlich um 150 milliarden enteignet
immer so ein paar steuerliche
kleinigkeiten dabei gar nicht reden zum
thema steuerentlastung oder
steuerbelastung mit 150 milliarden
werden die sparer in diesem land im
gleichschritt mit folgen für die
alterssicherung und alles was das talent
dafür werden ihnen steine statt brot
angepriesen 48% erkennende soll bleiben
keine beitragserhöhung keine
altersgrenzen erhöhung bei wänden
eindruck meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wer ein bisschen was von rent
versteht weiß dass das voodoo land ist
apropos voodoo lounge afghanistan ist
überall die mediale lobpreisungen des
euro durch den neuen finanzminister
hören sich an wie die schilderungen des
früheren außenministers dubai
afghanistan kurz vor dem zusammenbruch
in afghanistan der finanzminister
spricht von einem bahnbrechenden aufbau
für europa dass die jährliche deutsche
beitragsleistung von derzeit 130
milliarden sehr zeitnah in den nächsten
jahren auf über 60 milliarden steigen
wird erwähnt er nicht und zudem die
vorsitzende des
haushaltskontrollausschuss der eu
spricht soeben von der hohen
wahrscheinlichkeit der fehlleitung
dieser aufbau mittel von manipulierten
vergangen und von einer fehlen
kontrollmöglichkeit der eben die
koalition die kommission am schluss herr
präsident hat keine verbindung zur
wirklichkeit oder sie täuscht die
öffentlichkeit ganz bewusst über die
fatale lage dieses landes der gierige
griff nach öffentlichen ämtern ist keine
grundlage um die nächsten vier jahre
politisch zu überleben
berlin
[Applaus]
als nächste natürlich das wort den
kollegen christian kindler bündnis 90
die grünen
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren nach diesen schobel einmütig
zur sachpolitik zurückkommen
herr minister lindner ich freue mich auf
die zusammenarbeit mit ihnen und ihrem
haus und dass das bisher schon gut
funktioniert sehen gott ja gottschalk
sind nicht mehr dran sie hat in ihrer
zeit herr minister lindner echter
zusammenarbeit mit ihnen in ihrem haus
das schon sehr gut funktioniert zeigen
die wertige beratung zum
nachtragshaushalt ich freue mich auf das
was noch kommen wird in der zukunft denn
wir haben großen auftrag als ampel in
der haushalts und finanzpolitik wir
wollen nicht weniger als die großen
veränderungen dieser zeit angehen und
das ist die ökologische das ist aber
auch die soziale und digitale
transformation unserer gesellschaft und
unserer volkswirtschaft und ich sage
ganz bewusst dass wir dafür jetzt mit
anfangen müssen es geht um einen
startschuss war in den letzten jahren so
viel zeit verplempert wurde weil so viel
nicht passiert ist müssen wir jetzt
anfangen und jetzt endlich loslegen mit
der neuen regierung
und wie viel zeit wir verloren haben das
hat noch mal sehr eindrücklich die
eröffnungsbilanz zum klimaschutz von
robert habeck in dieser woche deutlich
gemacht und dabei geht es ja nichts
abstraktes beim klimaschutz unter einer
unserer klimaziele geht es um die
zentrale rettung unserer
lebensgrundlagen als menschen es geht um
die zukünftigen freiheitsrechte der
nachfolgende generationen deswegen freue
ich mich dass nach jahren der
arbeitsverweigerung jetzt die neue
bundesregierung mit einem sehr klaren
start programm mit einem neuen
klimaschutz support program loslegt und
diese aufgabe kraftvoll anpackt und
dafür dafür brauchen natürlich auch an
unsere finanzpolitik die die das auch
möglich gemacht wir haben der
koalitionsvereinbarung sehr deutlich
gesagt dass wir jetzt in diesem 20er
jahren ein jahrzehnt der
zukunftsinvestitionen wollen darf wir
alle möglichkeiten nutzen werden wie es
im haushalt uns gegeben sind wir werden
einen sehr klaren schwerpunkt auf
zukunftsinvestitionen in den kommenden
haushaltsberatungen legen
[Applaus]
und gleichzeitig darf haben der minister
und auch dennis rohde hingewiesen werden
wir massiv mit den ökonomischen und
sozialen gesundheitspolitischen folgen
der pandemie zu kämpfen haben und auch
gerade für die bewältigung der
ökonomischen folgen ist es notwendig
dass wir auf öffentliche investitionen
setzen das ist quasi der nachhaltige und
starke elektromotor um aus dieser krise
herauszukommen wir denken die pandemie
die bewältigung der pandemie und die
klimakrise zusammen das haben in diesem
nachtragshaushalt auch schon sehr
deutlich gemacht
und ich wundere mich denn auch etwas
über die kritik der union an diesem
nachtragshaushalt weil ja alle
ernstzunehmenden ökonomischen
sachverständigen oder anhörung am montag
nun mal sehr deutlich gemacht haben dass
die pandemie massive ökonomische
einschnitte unsere volkswirtschaft hatte
und auch in den nächsten jahren noch
haben wird es ist darauf hingewiesen vom
kollegen schrodi der professor jens
video com hat darauf hingewiesen dass
werden ökonomische slongo wird durch die
pandemie haben werden und gleichzeitig
sehr deutlich in der anderen klar
geworden dass danach das hast du dabei
hilft diese ökonomischen schäden auch
abzufedern und zu beseitigen und wie wir
diese ökonomische non profit bewältigen
das wollen wir mit öffentliche
investitionen öffentliche investitionen
und privatem besitz zu sagen dass impfen
der wirtschafts und finanzpolitik
deswegen sagen wie sehr klar wir wollen
investitions spritze für unsere
volkswirtschaft um diese pandemie
ökonomisch nachhaltig zu überwinden
[Applaus]
übrigens ist das auch internationaler
standard dass man das macht in italien
in spanien usa in kanada großbritannien
südkorea überall verbinden staaten große
industriestaaten die überwindung der
pandemie die ökonomischen folgen bei der
bildung der pandemie mit klimaschutz und
transformation und ich wurde nämlich
schon dass das von union jetzt so massiv
in frage gestellt wird was sie wollen
ist im kern deutschland
wirtschaftspolitischen finanzpolitisch
international isolieren und das werden
wir nicht zulassen wir werden sehr klar
machen was unser weg ist kürzer wohnung
und klimaschutz zusammen denken
und wir müssen natürlich auch darüber
reden wie wir in europa nachhaltiger
pandemie kommen extra ration eu ist ein
sehr zentraler wichtiger baustein und
instrument gewesen um diese pandemie zu
überwinden und gleichzeitig ökonomisch
und digital den nächsten jahren die
zukunft zu investieren
wären wir auch im koalitionsvertrag
gesagt dass wir für die frage von
europäischen digitalen netzen für die
frage der schieneninfrastruktur für die
frage von forschung entwicklung für
klimaschutz in diesen nächsten
jahrzehnten natürlich auch weitergehen
müssen brauchen der europäische
investitionsoffensive dem wollen wir
gemeinsam mit europäischen partnern
angehen und dafür werden wir in der
bundesregierung und parlament die
initiative ergreifen
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen auch aus der demokratischen
opposition ich freue mich auf die
weitere zusammenarbeit im
haushaltsausschuss in den kommenden
haushaltsberatungen werden viel zu tun
haben lassen wir uns angehen vielen dank
denn christian kinder der
haushaltspolitische sprecher von bündnis
90/die grünen und in der tat auf die
haushälter wird gerade in diesem jahr
doch einiges zukommen drei haushalte der
nachtragshaushalt der soll ja 2021 er
muss noch ende januar verabschiedet
werden und dann gibt es ja wegen des
wahljahres noch den haushalt 2022 zu
beschließen im moment gilt noch die
vorläufige haushaltsführung und auch für
2023 muss ja noch der haushalt beraten
und beschlossen werden herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ja man könnte bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner schon ein wenig als
lucky luke der deutschen politik
bezeichnet
als der mann der schneller umfeld als
sein eigener schatten kaum in der
regierung
kaum in der regierungsverantwortung hat
sein versprechen für solide finanzen
gerade einmal fünf tage gehalten das
dürfte ein negativrekord sein und heute
habe ich aus ihrer rede auch
rausgenommen und gelernt dass sie jetzt
auch in zukunft noch gegen eine
unternehmenssteuerreform sind also da
frage ich mich schon wo ist da der
markenkern der fdp verblieben
schon schon der erste nachtragshaushalt
der ampel koalition belastet
nachfolgende generationen immens und
doch wird bei dieser bundesregierung
meine vorredner haben es fast unisono
gemacht viel von nachhaltigkeit
gesprochen das was sie hier machen ist
alles andere aber wirklich auch alles
andere wie nachhaltig für die zukunft
unseres landes
was macht das auch für einen sinne
rückwirkend für das letzte jahr
zusätzliche schulden zu machen mit der
begründung man wolle kurzfristige
wirtschaftliche impulse setzen um der
pandemie entgegenzuwirken
das ist jetzt für das jahr 20 21 zu spät
das ganze eher geben falls man das geld
für zahlreiche zukünftige ausgabe
wünsche bunkern möchte so macht man aber
viel vertrauen in die fiskalpolitik
kaputt war 16 jahre unions regierung
mühsam aufgebaut hat es geht
ausschließlich darum die schuldenbremse
auszuhebeln und das wäre ja klar
verfassungswidrig
die anhörung mit fachexperten und
bundesrechnungshof vom montag war
bezeichnend der bundestag würde ich
sogar empfohlen den haushalt abzulehnen
ich denke eine wirklich einmalige
situation eine zwischenfrage das belegen
fricke fdp fraktion ja natürlich sehr
gerne
auch die rede
herr kollege aus na das sind ja sehr
komplexe vorgänge hier und ihr
ministerpräsident hat uns ja bereits
klargemacht dass die landesgruppe der
csu als abgrund mit komplexen
gesetzgebungs vorgängen so ihre
schwierigkeiten hat deswegen möchte ich
da doch noch mal nachfragen
kann ich ihre äußerungen zum
nachtragshaushalt so deuten dass sie der
meinung sind dass die bundesrepublik
deutschland sich in diesem jahr nicht
mehr in einer notsituation befindet
liebe julia pflege fricke herzlichen
dank erstmal für die frage und ich lasse
jetzt den stückweit arroganten teil zu
beginn juni-wert toren weg ich denke
jeder hat seinen blick weise auf den
haushalt aber nein es widerspricht in
keinster weise wenn sie sagen dass in 20
22 die pandemie nach wie vor besteht
dann können sie in dem haushalt
2022 die fällt die veranschlagten
ausgaben hier verbuchen aber nicht
rückwirkend ins waren 22
den kopf gehen lassen
der haushaltsentwurf 22 wie bereits
gesagt würde ausreichend möglichkeit
bieten die im koalitionsvertrag
angekündigten auch klimaschutzprojekte
in richtung der grünen
einzubringen das wäre meine lieben aber
koalitionäre ehrliche finanz und
haushaltspolitik erlauben sie mir zu den
bereichen digital ist ein verkehr auch
noch ein paar takte zu sagen weil es mir
wirklich am herzen liegt links gelbe
koalition brems projekt aus wo sie
beschleunigen möchte sie den straßenbau
moratorium sie heitz preise an wo sie
dämpfen müsste sie die energiepreise und
sie vernichten anreize da wo sie welche
setzen sollte sie alternative
kraftstoffe und israels beziehungsweise
auch mit wasserstoff für mich wäre es
ein absolutes desaster für die mobilität
standard deutschland
zum zum breitband mobilfunk ausbau
verliert die sogenannte fortschritts
koalition nur wenige worte der
flächendeckenden glasfaserausbau wird
ausgebremst zum leidwesen vieler bürger
die auf schnelles internet angewiesen
sind wiederum zeigt sich dass vor allem
der ländliche raum der große verlierer
ihrer politik ist bitte vergessen sie
mir nicht über die hälfte der
bundesdeutschen bevölkerung liebe neue
linz gelbe regierung
rekord inflation macht das leben in
deutschland immer teurer gleichzeitig
fressen niedrigzinsen das erspart die
viele bürger auf wer 60 milliarden euro
mit fraglicher verfassungsmäßigkeit
bunkern kann sollte auch in der lage
sein zügig eine steuer tarifanpassung
auf den weg zu bringen die union hatte
in den vergangenen jahren stets die
vermeidung von heimlichen
steuererhöhungen stichwort kalte
progression gegen die spd durchgesetzt
unter der ampel tod diese politik der
entlastung nun völlig unter die räder zu
kommen und es werden zwar
steuererleichterungen versprochen welche
am ende jedoch keine sinn weil längst
von der vorgängerregierung schon
beschlossen früher hieß es immer ist
mein letzter satz herr präsident die
roten können nicht mit geld umgehen das
gilt wohl für alle in der rot-grünen
koalition herzliches vergelts dort fürs
zuhören
der bundestag debattiert in dieser woche
über die vorhaben der ampel koalition in
dieser legislaturperiode und heute
stehen noch die ressorts unter anderem
wie wir gerade hören ihr haushalt und
finanzen hier auf der tagesordnung aber
der nächste punkt das nächste ressort
sozusagen ist schon ein gericht weit in
ungefähr 20 minuten geht es los mit
ernährung und landwirtschaft und mit dem
neuen minister dazu kämen bis zum so
jetzt aber noch eine neue abgeordnete
hier mit ihrer ersten rede wie
papenbrock von der spd zum thema
haushalt und finanzen
ich bin neu im deutschen bundestag und
bin im haushaltsausschuss zuständig für
das auswärtige amt und weil es zu meinem
heutigen thema passt und ich darauf dass
ich auch noch mal zurückkommen werde ich
habe ein auslandsjahr in neuseeland
verbracht warum erzähle ich das weil ich
dank eines arbeitsvisum selbst davon
profitiert haben dass deutschland
abkommen trifft die es uns ermöglichen
andere länder und kulturen besser kennen
oder überhaupt erst kennen zu lernen das
ist ja keine selbstverständlichkeit
die neue bundesregierung hat sich
vorgenommen den internationalen
austausch weiter zu fördern
aber werden wir zunächst einen kurzen
blick zurück in die frühere
bundesregierung hat sich in den
internationalen beziehungen hat viel auf
den weg gebracht um hat viel investiert
in der vergangenheit wurden zum beispiel
die goethe-institute gestärkt davon gibt
es weltweit
158 in 98 ländern ihre aufgabe ist es
das bild deutschlands und die deutsche
kultur im ausland zu repräsentieren und
die deutsche sprache zu pflegen
und die institute exportieren im besten
fall dialog und meinungsfreiheit in
ländern in denen beides keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist
70 millionen euro haben die goethe
institute und die deutschen
auslandsschulen mit dem
nachtragshaushalt 20 20 jeweils
zusätzlich erhalten um panini bedingte
einnahme einbußen aufzufangen
was möchte nun diese bundesregierung
erreichen dass die welt sich ändert und
spannung zu nehmen sehen wir ganz
deutlich an den grenzen europas und wir
sehen es natürlich an den vielen
krisenherden in der welt an der
flüchtlingskrise in belarus an den
humanitären krisen und an den
bürgerkriegen in jemen sudan und
äthiopien und das sind ja lange nicht
alle
wir wollen hier müssen wir den zugang zu
humanitärer hilfe verbessern und auch
den helferinnen und helfern vor ort
wir müssen mehr schützen mehr schutz
zukommen lassen
schon jetzt macht die humanitäre hilfe
im etat des auswärtigen amtes ein
drittel aus und diese hilfe ist
überlebenswichtig für millionen menschen
deshalb werden wir die mittel für die
humanitäre hilfe erhöhen zum beispiel
für afghanistan die entwicklung des
landes hat uns alle im letzten jahr
stark berührt um hier eine humanitäre
katastrophe zu verhindern werden wir die
hilfsorganisationen der vereinten
nationen finanziell und personell
unterstützen
für unsere gemeinsam außenpolitischen
ziele ist eine kooperation mit unseren
partnern in der welt enorm wichtig und
es gibt auch andere beispiele so ist und
bleibt zum beispiel großbritannien auch
nach dem wechsel einer unserer engsten
partner außerhalb der eu auf diese
zusammenarbeit werden wir weiter pflegen
und intensivieren
insgesamt wollen wir solche programme
ausbauen die unterschiedliche
gesellschaften kulturen und menschen
zusammenbringen hier denke ich zum
beispiel an die bildungspolitik
zu ihr gehören auch die deutschen
schulen im ausland
dieses netz soll ausgebaut werden
wir wollen das interesse an unserem land
bei jungen menschen stärken wir wollen
dass sie gerne in unsere schulen kommen
und lust haben unsere sprache und unsere
kultur kennenzulernen
man muss auch den beginn meiner rede
zurück wir wollen die persönliche
begegnung und den persönlichen austausch
von menschen aus verschiedenen ländern
und kulturen stärken damit viele so eine
schöne und bereichernde erfahrung machen
können wie ich sie mit anfang 20 in
neuseeland machen dürfte und auch damit
deutschland seiner verantwortung für
frieden für die wahrung der
menschenrechte und die bekämpfung von
krieg und armut in der welt nach punkt
war das für die spd fraktion eine der
neuen abgeordneten hier im deutschen
bundestag mit ihrer ersten rede sie
kommt aus brandenburg hat dort ihren
wahlkreis direkt gewonnen
prignitz ostprignitz ruppin und
havelland und da gibt es doch ein
bisschen glückwünsche von den
fraktionskollegen wie das üblich ist bei
ersten reden sohn ist gehen wir mal
schnell zum nächsten regen sebastian
brehm für die regierung
die bundesregierung wird dazu
aufgefordert bei der aufstellung der
bundeshaushalte 2009/10 ford folgende
den bundeszuschuss zum energie- und
klimafonds ekf bis
2021 so weit wie möglich abzubauen diese
mittel aus dem sondervermögen lpkf
sollen wieder aus gründen der
haushaltsklarheit
in dem ressort haushalt rück
strukturiert werden das ist ein antrag
der fdp aus dem jahr 2018 und kaum ist
christian lindner
finanzminister macht er genau das
gegenteil von dem was er gefordert hat
vorher eher befüllt nämlich genau dieses
sondervermögen
mit 60 milliarden euro für
rot-gelb-grüne wahlgeschenke unter
umgehung der schuldenbremse und zu
lasten der nächsten generation das
werden wir ihnen nicht durchgehen lassen
ich lese nur einen satz aus dem
gutachten des bundesrechnungshofes vom 6
122 zu ihrem nachtragshaushalt indes
beschlossen wird vor der
bundesrechnungshof hält den entwurf des
zweiten nachtragshaushaltes sie wollen
das nächste woche beschließen
2021 für
verfassungsrechtlich zweifelhaft
und so was bringen sie ein unter dem
thema haushaltsklarheit also letztlich
wird es überprüft werden müssen anders
gesagt liebe kolleginnen kollegen
finanzpolitik mit christian lindner das
ist ein bisschen wie hütchen spielen am
anfang wird ein satter gewinn in
aussicht gestellt dann wird getrickst
dann wird geschoben und am ende haben
alle weniger geld in der tasche und
im bereich steuern liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen schreibt die wirtschaftswoche
am zweiten januar 22 christian lindner
erlebt sein hohem niveau mit der
realität bei keiner partei klaffen
wahlversprechen und koalitionsvertrag in
dieser weise auseinander was ist von
ihren forderungen geblieben
vollständiger abbau von sony nichts
davon im koalitionsvertrag umgesetzt
mittelstandsbauch kalte progression
abschaffen tarif auf rädern nichts davon
im koalitionsvertrag umgesetzt
entlastung kleinerer und mittlerer
einkommen nichts davon den
koalitionsvertrag umgesetzt und
steuerentlastung für familien und eine
moderne unternehmensbesteuerung heute
haben sie es ja noch mal abgelehnt
nichts davon im koalitionsvertrag
umgesetzt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das einzige was umgesetzt oder das
einzige was umgesetzt wurde sind sie
hier im parlament und wenn man hier
übrigens von vorne guckt weiß ich jetzt
auch warum weil sie nach links gezogen
sind sie haben genau das widergespiegelt
was ihre aktuelle politische haltung
darstellt
die fdp
die fdp hat immer gesagt wir wollen
nicht nur als steuersenkungspartei
wahrgenommen werden ich kann sie
beruhigen mit christian linden aber
ihnen das garantiert nicht mehr
passieren herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
der bremer das für die cdu csu fraktion
ja der nachtrag sollten 2021
60 milliarden euro sollen in den energie
und klimafonds geschoben werden diese
energie und klima von der ist ja nicht
neu der ist schon 2011 eingerichtet
worden als sondervermögen des bundes
manche sagen auch
nebenhaushalt wenn diese 60 milliarden
dahingehen ende januar wird darüber
abgestimmt dann liegen da immerhin
gigantischen 103 milliarden euro für
investitionen förderungen und
subventionen bereit
sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren ich möchte mit ihrer erlaubnis
der präsident mit einem zitat beginn der
klimawandel ist eine der größten
herausforderung vor der wir jemals in
der menschheit gestanden haben
das hat friedrich merz gesagt ein
richtige erkenntnis
immerhin
aber so groß diese herausforderung
völlig unbestritten auch ist sage ich
trotzdem wenn es nur das wäre wenn es
nur der klimawandel werde denn wir
müssen zugleich auch die rasante
digitalisierung und die notwendige
transformation unserer wirtschaft
bewältigen eine herausforderung die von
der größenordnung her nicht zu unrecht
mit der industriellen revolution
verglichen wird und wir müssen als
drittes mega-thema mit dem
demografischen wandel umgehen die schon
jetzt an allen ecken und enden in
deutschland fehlenden fachkräfte sind
dabei nur die ersten vorboten davon was
uns da erwartet
damit nicht genug
diese dreifache herausforderung aus
klimawende digitalisierung und
demografischer entwicklung stetig in
einem deutlicheren internationalen
umfeld deutschland und europa müssen
sich in einem nicht selten
rücksichtslosen wettbewerb mit china und
den usa behaupten um es mit einem bild
zu sagen wir stehen am ostseestrand und
hoffen dass sich die korona wolken
endlich verziehen aber wir wissen schon
dass ich da etwas zusammenbraut und was
sich da zusammenbraut sieht aus wie der
perfekte sturm die gute nachricht die
ampelkoalition aus spd grünen und fdp
nimmt diese dreifache herausforderung an
und arbeitet mit hochdruck und mit
großer ernsthaftigkeit daran dass wir
unser land so schnell wie möglich
wetterfest machen endlich
genau deshalb wollen wir und werden wir
die 2020er jahre kollege kindle als auch
gesagt zu einem jahrzehnt der
zukunftsinvestitionen machen in
klimaschutz in digitalisierung in
bildung in forschung und in die
infrastruktur
währenddessen stehen cdu/csu aller
erkenntnis zum trotz daneben und
erklären der öffentlichen deutschen
öffentlichkeit fortwährend was aus ihrer
sicht alles nicht geht vorschläge wie
wir diese dringend notwendigen
zukunftsinvestitionen finanzieren wollen
fehlanzeige
verantwortung für deutschland meine
damen und herren sieht anders aus
das betrifft im übrigen auch die
diskussion ob der bundestag 60
milliarden euro an kredit ermächtigungen
an den klimafonds übertragen darf es ist
unstreitig dass der staat in einer
solchen außergewöhnlichen notsituationen
impfstoff kaufen krankenhäuser
finanzieren und unternehmen helfen kann
und es ist ebenfalls unstreitig dass der
staat allgemeine konjunkturstützende
maßnahmen ergreifen kann zum beispiel
durch eine temporäre
mehrwertsteuersenkung wie wir sie
gemacht haben
jetzt geht es rechtlich gesehen um eine
weit weniger weitreichende maßnahme
stadt ganz allgemein die konjunktur zu
stützen sollen die mittel ausschließlich
investiv eingesetzt werden und dann auch
nur für solche investitionen die
zukunftsgerichtet die transformation
unserer wirtschaft und die klimawende
schleuniger ökonomisch sinnvoll ist das
ohnehin gerade weil die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung so fragil ist und weil wir
aufgrund der pandemie entwicklung auch
jederzeit mit rückschlägen rechnen
müssen und daran ändert im übrigen
sowohl rechtlich als auch ökonomisch
nicht dass diese mittel nicht sofort
abfließen
investitionen haben immer einen vorlauf
aber die unternehmen reagieren eben
immer sofort und passen ihre planungen
an und weiten ihre kapazitäten auf und
stellen mitarbeiter innen ein und das
hat eben eine unmittelbar
konjunkturstützende und stabilisierende
wirkung
das meine damen und herren brauchen wir
in anbetracht der aktuellen unsicherheit
das ist eine verantwortungsvolle politik
wir machen diese politik und dann sitzen
wir auch bald wieder bei sonnenschein am
ostseestrand vielen dank
die gruppe war das für die spd fraktion
der letzte der hier das wort zu diesem
ressort hatte thema haushalt und
finanzen
[Musik]